in five four three two one boom boom
boom boom
salutations everybody welcome to another
episode of the genius brain podcast I am
your host David so and we have joke
[ __ ] Jitsu Kawa [ __ ] what's up
ese
hey what's up I'd say so what's going on
man hello yeah this fool Joe has been
sick forever dude like he's been
coughing up you're so funny like you
came in you're like now I'm good to
Train I'm good
and we're like you sure you okay if I
can't man it's a [ __ ] dudes a [ __ ] as
I brought some Monday you don't even
know where you're at right now they're
all [ __ ] up you go a little too hand
man you gotta just bring that [ __ ] down
a little bit I just don't know when it's
time to rest your mind is a very
powerful thing too I realized that you
could convince yourself a [ __ ]
anything I thought it was a it could be
it could do better
oh my god dude how was the workout that
was it okay it was good man I have had
it's this has been the longest stint of
me not being active yeah and I started
feeling him and I was all getting
frustrated I was like man this is
something I need you get that little you
get irritated don't you yeah a little
agitated that's how I was when I was
when I was in Jersey I summed up for
just like a week membership at a UFC gym
just so I could go and hit the bag every
day do something because I felt like I
was gonna lose my mind and also I
realized what a true extrovert I was
because on Saturday I did a meet and
greet at June be right in Westwood so we
had a lot of fans did like two three
hours and then after that we went to do
us a shop with our team leaders for all
of our restaurants from oh yeah and then
I did like a two-hour speech from I
don't know seven eight nine right by the
end of that I should have been tired you
know the opposite happened I got home
that energized her ass huh bro I was at
10 p.m. and I felt like a like a [ __ ]
dictator that just gave a war speech you
know like I was like going on I feel all
this fire and then I can't rest so I'm
like I can't go to sleep at 10 right now
so I put on my running shoes and
I [ __ ] put on some straight-up gypsy
music when I just like his gypsy bro my
god this is a different story but I got
into some gypsy music man I was looking
for some like you know Romanian music or
whatever and so Romani is the correct
term for the gypsy culture
I heard gypsy in the wrong word but I
don't know in America I don't think it
has the same stigma but over there it's
different yeah but Romani or is not the
same as Romanian Romanian is its own
country with its own set of people oh
it's very different and the Romani
people are traveling you know that the
the the the the stigma the traveling
gypsy or whatever they came from like
India and then they went up the Middle
East and then they went all around
Europe so they're they're basically a
mystery but they speak a dialect that
sounds like northern Indian or whatever
and so so anyways I was looking for
Romanian music and I fell upon this and
at first it was really funny it's called
like the genres call like Mennella or
something like that and I and I just
thought it was the funniest thing I've
ever seen but you know with me and
interesting music I get addicted what
the [ __ ] does Romanian music sound like
it's not Romanian oh it's it's it's it's
it's it's a Romani it's the moment he's
music it's a it's a it's the gypsy stuff
yeah
Romanians will actually get mad if you
call that their music people are [ __ ]
labels man damn it
I understand it's different right I
understand because oh they also get a
bad rep because people mistake the two
okay so then they they're like we're not
the same and I think it's the same as
like Slovakia and Slovenia pne's it's so
similar mmm but it's not it's like it's
not yeah yeah but anyways um yeah so I'm
I'm I have this music playing I'm like
ready to [ __ ] go if kind of sounds
like mariachi there's like accordion
didn't you do like [ __ ] poke gun [ __ ]
[ __ ] okay it's me pop bro like I'll show
you later you'll start cracking the [ __ ]
up they have the most craziest music
videos it's nuts
so I'm
running right I'm running my two miles
I'm [ __ ] on it I get home I'm doing
pull-ups and [ __ ]
doing a pull-up push-ups and [ __ ] I'm
just like plus ups that's what the
ladies like I do plus ups [ __ ] and then
I get to sleep it's like midnight or
1:00 I'm laying down and I'm so amped
the [ __ ] up dude and I'm like damn so I
do charge my batteries up with people
that's [ __ ] yeah yeah and then that is a
true sign of an extrovert like I I
always feel weird because I'm think I'm
more of an introvert but I do understand
what it feels like to get energy from
people cuz as a stand-up comedian right
yeah so sometimes when I do stand-up or
if I do these Q&A at colleges which is
what I've been I which I prefer to do
more than stand up now because the Q&A
is essentially is you're at you're
actually getting a stand-up set but
there's it's more geared towards what
the person says so is crowd work
basically it's improv it's improv not
work but you know there are serious
topics that are brought up and I like
answering them so I it's it's it's
basically a live genius brain now yeah
when I do these college shows but and we
should start doing live genius on we
will be doing live genius soon are a
part of a student organization or
whatever here's nothing on us out there
where can they get the info just hit up
David so comedy booking for that type of
stuff if it's like if it's genius brain
stuff - if it's for booking shows is
David so comedy booking but at gmail.com
gmail.com so yeah I definitely do so
when I was at this College called TCNJ I
think they were testing it was like a
version of like Pete some people call it
like maybe Princeton but you could tell
like that school is very academia
focused because of the type of questions
that were being asked like what
like so so certain schools - like mind
you I could tell like they just wanted
like a fun person to be at the school so
people would ask like well you know what
size shoes do I do it always say [ __ ]
like that it's the last question of the
night you guys make sure it's good and
then some guy raises his hand he goes
hey Bart
how much do you is your bench live I'm
like are you a [ __ ] college student
what kind of question is that
yeah and everyone's all like oh that was
the last
you know I I always get this one type
book there's a couple of type of college
students that I get at these shows
there's one where they're the ones that
are ready to party and just have fun
which is dope too but there's this other
subset where they feel like they're
above college and they're smarter than
their peers those are the ones that I
hate the [ __ ] most all those snobs
there snobby a [ __ ] and you think that
they're more mature and older than their
posh suck my dick so like now I'm alive
if you're hot I'm a lot nicer about it
when I get this but there was recently
somebody who asked this question and
there's always it's not just this person
- it wasn't that this college toured but
it was last year but somebody asked the
same question that was just a lot nicer
about it this time but the first prior
to me just saying like I'm gonna be
nicer about how I approach these people
it's just they always do this where they
go it's this question I always get a big
oh hey David I you know I know a lot of
people here are asking like you know
very surface level like questions that
first of all number one now you're just
saying that you're better than everybody
else right now yeah cuz I'm gonna ask
better [ __ ] exactly I already don't like
that yeah off the bat like these are
your peers you're not talkin [ __ ] about
them like that first of all all of my
peers are [ __ ] idiots but not me
that's because I'm gonna tell you
something way better that's exactly what
they're saying right and the second
thing that it always falls up with is I
just want to know like personally like
how you're doing like how are you it's
like you get those I get that question
almost every time I do a college show
maybe because you sound like a depressed
bass bass so I asked you know not not to
this guy who asked this time I just kind
of answer nicely I was like you know
what I'm good
but before but last year was somebody
asked that question and he said it in
more of a snobby way cuz he was sliding
the people in the crowd and I and when I
said to this guy was I was like hey let
me ask you something man I was like when
you ask that question what is your
objective like why are you asking that
question he goes like because I feel
like celebrities people don't realize
that you guys are people too so I just
want to know genuinely how you're doing
only is such a self-righteous [ __ ]
exactly I was like so really what you're
doing right now is you're asking that
question to glorify yourself you're not
actually asking me how I'm doing is what
you're trying to make it sound what
you're saying right now is that I am
better than my peers around you and
they're all asking dumb questions isn't
that what you're doing
dead silent right yeah I'll say because
that's what it comes off as I was like
number two who the [ __ ] are you if I
wasn't doing well you think I would do
it on this public platform right
and tell you specifically what the [ __ ]
are you thinking right now and the kid
just got super quiet I was like I'll
tell you why that and the third reason
why I don't like that quite like the
third reason why I don't like that
question is because you are you think
that you're a lot smarter than you
actually are
you're not right everybody here is on
equal ground
so the fact that you would come out here
and then just literally just [ __ ]
bash everybody in the crowd anybody who
asked the question yeah and mind you
sell me these questions yeah they are
kind of dumb but they're just here to
have fun
you didn't have to do that bro yeah you
know the [ __ ] down I just moved on the
guy who it was funny because almost in
the exact same way this last show
somebody asked that but I didn't do it
that that's the time I just taught him
like yeah I'm doing great I'm fine but
it was just it annoys me sometimes just
like why do you have to do that like why
do you have to act like number one
you're better than somebody else or
number two you don't have to act like
you're more mature than you actually are
it's okay I mean let me try to dissect
that like I'm trying to get into that
mindset right yeah oh my god that's like
that [ __ ] for me because I'm like that
I'm trying to figure out why okay if I
were to do that and I'm hiding my ego
it's like okay so there's a
self-righteousness right so he might be
going like this you know what everyone
here is asking these stupid questions we
need to get to the Nitty Gritty they're
just so selfish let's let's let's we you
know let's talk about David David you're
out here servicing everyone else and
you're answering their questions but how
about you man
well I was like things like what what do
you expecting me to go what would have
came out of that you know and he's like
he's probably like broke come here hug
bro I knew I knew you were hurting
inside it's like and everyone claps at
him it was just like the most
self-righteous self-serving thing that I
like I get asked consistently it's just
like I understand - it's because that's
something that somebody would ask
because now because there is this new
rhetoric
online we're like people don't ever
really show how they actually feel which
is true however the reason why you said
that the reason why I was irritated
because you're not actually asking me
how I'm doing yeah you're trying to make
yourself look good in front of a group
of random people right now you know so
if even if you took me to the side say
how are you really doing I still
wouldn't tell you [ __ ] face I don't know
who the [ __ ] you are
really I would double down life is so
hot that's kind of like when you're at a
cash register right and then when a lady
asks you how you doing it's like do you
really want to know like I like you
really you know kid at the last college
if you're listening to this stuff like
I'm not [ __ ] on you like I
understand I'm kind of harsh in my
approach I'm really brash like I'm
learning not to do that as much unless
it's for a joke so actually I'll do it
all the time however it's funny but it's
funny like I get it you know people are
cracking up when I was roasting them of
course you know because they saw it too
it's not idiots yeah people are dumb I
think people deserve to be called out
for having no tact yeah if you're
standing there and you're you have you
might have good intentions right but
you're out here insulting people this is
what I say everyone has good intentions
everyone thinks that they're doing the
right thing but if your execution sucks
you deserve to be called out on it
now because what matters is the result
what matters is what came out of what
you expressed not how you really felt
about it
yes I do this all the time there's been
a couple of times on Twitter where I
made jokes about something without
really looking at what I was making a
joke at and I did take that [ __ ] down
and apologize and I won't typically
apologize for a lot of jokes if the
intent is for funny stuff this podcast
is brought to you by purple my friends
purple mattress dun bless my body up so
good I've never slept so well in my life
that is a power that is a power of a
purple Manchester yes purple mattresses
have been or one of the biggest
blessings in my life because I was
sleeping on a crap box before a huge
crap box and I had no idea how important
sleep was to me I had no idea how much
back comfort was to me when it came to
sleeping and the purple mattress
approved everything that I thought wrong
I thought I needed to sleep on a slab of
rock in order to sleep better
because I was told that by old ancient
Asian people and guess what it's
different it's not for me
I need a mattress that feels right for
me that keeps me cool at night and has
actual rocket scientists developed the
material behind it and that's a purple
mattress baby
so my friends a hundred night risk-free
trial if you're not fully satisfied you
can return your mattress for a full
refund backed by a 10 year warranty free
shipping and returns you're going to
love purple and right now my listeners
will get a free purple pillow with the
purchase of a mattress that's in
addition to the great gifts they're
offering site-wide just explain to 84-88
the only way to get this free pillow is
a text brain to a four - eight eight
eight that's BR a I n two eight four
eight eight eight message and data rates
may apply but if I [ __ ] up and I didn't
really read everything that I'm like I
miss it so for example there was this
tick tock it's not funny but there's
this girl she was this lady was showing
on tick tock which for me I thought tick
tock was only used for funny [ __ ] so I
assumed it was a comedy video she's like
I'm not to go outside for a jog and so
she started hiding all these weapons in
her hair so this is in case a man
touches me and she puts like pins in her
hair and all these like secret weapons
and stuff and hiding her phone and her
socks and I was like [ __ ] where the
[ __ ] do you live like she's like a ninja
yeah I'm like [ __ ] move [ __ ] out of his
neighborhood but that tick-tock was
about her saying like she was actually a
sexually assaulted and raped before so
now this is what women have to go
through well so she was pretty much
building an arsenal before she went on a
jog yeah so cuz because of the trauma
that she had so she was making a
statement about what women have to go
through however it was on tick tock yeah
and it was it seemed from a comedians
eye it looked like a joke so I made this
joke I was like [ __ ] the [ __ ] do you
live move [ __ ] you know yeah cuz it's
not safe and then people were tween like
yo man you didn't watch the whole video
and i was like oh [ __ ] so I took it down
and I was like yo didn't realize that
was a serious video because she did it
on tick tock tick tock was only for
comedy [ __ ] I didn't know that so I'm
you know I'm get a [ __ ] flaw
and I've definitely [ __ ] up on my own
platforms for sure like when that so
when that shooting happened at the
Gilroy Garlic Festival when it was first
announced
nobody was hurt so people didn't die so
I made this joke where we
Tim and I were supposed to go to that
Gilroy Garlic Festival and then last
minute I couldn't go so it got shut down
guys got lucky we got lucky right it was
cuz it was Gina's birthday so we decided
that we told him that we couldn't go
because it was Gina's birthday and so we
didn't go and then I tweeted I was like
damn I'm glad I didn't go because the
story would have read famous youtuber
dies and some fat asian guy next to him
I knew yeah and that [ __ ] had like two
thousand likes people are cracking up if
there was a some people were like hey my
cousin actually got hurt from there like
can you please take this down I was like
oh [ __ ] I don't know people actually got
shot cuz the first of all like you
didn't know that someone got injured the
first report was that nobody got hurt I
see but then people did get hurt some
people died so I was like nah that's not
funny somebody's really hurting take
that [ __ ] down it's touchy too because
the jokes too soon way too soon just any
shooting even if people didn't get hurt
yeah cuz that is pretty funny if people
didn't get hurt
that's a homies that's a homies joke
yeah if people didn't get hurt though no
joke no joke I would've left it up
really yep because nobody got hurt I
guess so
like it was shootings it's just such a
touchy subject right now though it
always is but like as long as somebody
personally didn't get hurt I'm okay
that's we're making a joke about it
because it's not about shooting it's a
joke that I'm not famous right that's
the joke yes obviously when somebody
lost their life there's less collateral
in your joke if there's no knowing that
got hurt you know exactly so yeah if
nobody got shot I would have left that
joke up and people would have understood
it's just somebody physically got hurt
as people passed away from it and now
I'm making a mockery of somebody's death
and I'm like that might go with that
I'll take that [ __ ] don't that's crazy
dude yeah well just to get into the
genius brain topic for today just to get
into specificities my friends
we got patreon topics right here so
we're still going through some of the
old ones I'm gonna put up on the patreon
another list of you guys being very
specific about issues that you guys
could talk about or anything that you're
generally curious about it doesn't have
to be specific problems but if you love
these a heads up you guys do them okay
so we're gonna omit this news name this
guy's name is Brandon bland with a with
a solid L blonde on so hey David and Joe
I've been a huge supporter of the both
of you since the earliest days of
YouTube now keep doing what you're doing
and I'm loving the podcasts I will suck
your dick later
just like that did all dry tongue so my
topic is pretty personal it revolves
around me dating fixing what you messed
up and move and with moving on oh very
nice I think we've all been through that
[ __ ] I am 24 a couple of months ago I
was a keynote speaker at a convention ok
light flex oh wow and it focused on
pursuing your own career in your
respective industry why it's important
and how to keep it going while I am
there I met someone who easily captured
my I love at first sight oh I'm so glad
because I just gave a keynote speech
hell yes she saw me as I [ __ ]
alpha dude 24 is still the age of random
boners where you dick just gets hard for
no goddamn reason I know what that's
like then she was annoying while I am
there I meant someone who easily
captured my I didn't know who she was I
didn't know what she did all I knew is
that this girl was beautiful smart and
driven and I got her number
okay keynote speaker nice that's what
I'm saying by the way this dude is Asian
so anybody out there said agen dudes can
get [ __ ] shut the [ __ ] up he was a
keynote speaker boss ass [ __ ] and he
got a number home he got them digits we
just keep crushing those [ __ ] arguments
yeah shoutouts to this guy bland dome as
I am there I realized she was also a
guest speaker Oh a lot of speakers
regarding her field which is music and
the entertainment industry well I
thought to myself that this girl was out
of my league I didn't think much of it
however she gave me a call at night
later and we hit it off out the park
love it as I headed back home after my
trip where we were connecting very well
intellectually and emotionally oh you
got my mind [ __ ] each other
this was the first girl that I had met
and had a lot up there was a lot of
cylinders firing the girls I've talked
to weren't like this and weren't this
down to be open so we started sharing
intimate moments about her life about
our life why we were in the industries
that we were in and we started to become
a part of each other's lives and we were
opening up everything seemed to be going
smoothly nothing was ever official since
it was long-distance and we were still
in the getting to know each other phase
okay so I guess after that day they
moved on and they started connecting
online and stuff after roughly four
weeks however I made a joke in response
to what she texted me and one of her
hobbies which was
Kars knowing that she was in the
entertainment industry and modeling as
well I made a joke regarding to her
doing import modeling she got very upset
with my joke and we spoke again that
night on her side ending things and that
escalated real quick why why is she so
sensitive about import modeling what the
[ __ ] we know some girls who did some
import modeling and there's some bad
[ __ ] yeah what's wrong with that her
reasons were because I was becoming a
fan and she doesn't date fans how how
did that how did that happen that's
interesting she said I was sexualizing
her and not seeing her for who she is
at 3 I was being too clingy know things
don't really jump like that though so
there's definitely he probably didn't
read a lot of the things that he might
have been doing yeah it's been it looks
like it's been boiling and then BOOM she
drops it on him like I can't do this
anymore
yeah because just just just from because
in his eyes he's like things are going
great everybody is he everybody's a hero
in their own story so when you when you
write these things this I I find it
really hard to believe that things just
happened overnight where she was like I
can't take this anymore
like what happened and unfortunately
many guys including myself can be
clueless yeah I am very clueless I
[ __ ] relate to this so much we need
to with my very first girlfriend I was
somewhat like this where even when I
could see the problems before me like I
knew it was there
there was a part of me that chose to
ignore it yep and then when the dumping
happened I was like I can't believe this
is happening yeah it's like what do you
mean dude it was there was huge signs as
to why this is gonna happen you chose
specifically to delete it out because
you didn't want to recognize the doom
that was coming and I think most people
are rarely irrational and crazy were
they just all of a sudden start reacting
to the things that you do especially
because he said that they were
connecting emotionally and
intellectually to so do respect her on
on something more than just a physical
level so doesn't seem that yeah maybe
she is an erratic person I don't really
know her but but someone joke and no
warning sign exactly erratic people
they're erratic from the jump point very
soon yeah like they can't hold
that mm-hmm you don't talk to someone
and you're like oh my god we connect
intellectually and emotionally and
there's no warning signs there's no
prior arguments there's nothing and then
all of a sudden boom something happens
and they completely want to end it yeah
that I kind of find that really really
because in most cases you have your
first argument right but most in those
cases you don't end it you just argue
yeah and you go oh we just had our first
argument Wow mm-hmm right and at least
in my experience I've never had anything
where from one mistake or one argument
they all of a sudden start dropping
these things of like your character your
behavior your whole personality and then
all of a sudden it's done and this very
some very specific ass [ __ ]
now this either this person is a unique
case of a lady who's been gathering
evidence and never vocalizing it or even
showing you signs and then pretending
and keeping piece until she couldn't
take it anymore and then she just went
all off you know but it also this is
this Windell opportunity I think when
people voice their opinion and fire back
at you that's a to me I see as a window
of opportunity to actually try to remedy
it but in her case she was done so that
means she had a lot of time to think
about it she had multiple times of where
she was rubbed the wrong way and she's
like I don't know if this is gonna be
cool or whatever and then she drops it
for sure like it doesn't sound it's just
it's too convenient right that you in
this story are the perfect man you are
having the perfect relationship and that
one little joke is the reason why she
just flips out and then dumps it doesn't
sound feasible to me yeah yeah it just
doesn't it doesn't it doesn't make any
sense
socially like and I'm playing all the
I'm trying my best to be on his side to
in to see because we're seeing a lot of
the flaws that we because I think I
would have written a story like this
when I was younger at 24 100% until
afterwards where I had time to reflect I
was like damn I was kind of a [ __ ]
loser
you know yeah not even Luther just blind
just blind to this [ __ ] like we weren't
emotionally stupid yeah we don't read
the things that they're trying to tell
us yeah and you're in he's young too so
yeah I get it you know he might be
having a blast going like haha [ __ ]
funny jokes huh
and he just keeps firing off mad jokes
and then she's like [ __ ] this guy I'm
just gonna be nice
the only there's really only one rom-com
that I really [ __ ] liked and it
pertains to this subject right here it's
a 500 days of summer Joseph
gordon-levitt is retelling this court
the story and recounting things of all
of why they were madly in love and how
heartbroken it is that they that it
didn't work out but there were signs
that their relationship was falling
apart that he chose to ignore yeah
and he was so oblivious because he
wanted things to be his way and I think
for a lot of guys this is true yeah
I've seen so many guys pretty much marry
the girl in their minds before things
were official yeah they're in such
belief of their own story and their own
like dream that they're not listening to
the girl they're not really connecting
to her they're having the relationship
by themselves and then the girl's
frustrated and she's like what the [ __ ]
bro like it's not that great because
you're just living this obsession I
think a lot of people do that in in the
in the beginning stages of their
relationship where they kind of they put
the dick or the [ __ ] on a pedestal
right so they they see this image of
this perfect human being and when they
don't match up to that person they get
disappointed and it's something that
really wasn't there and it sounds like
he started that way because he
immediately said when I was at the
keynote speech and she was she was she
was yeah and she was out of my league
mmm so here and she says you put me on a
pedestal yeah evidence number one he
came into their relationship or this
encounter already with a lower sense of
self and and she's in a higher position
so the way he's been treating her is oh
you are my goddess that's probably where
the whole sexualizing her and not seeing
of her for who she is that he might be
all day saying you're so beautiful
you're so beautiful you know so - you're
so sexy and if you're a keynote speaker
at this event as well I'm pretty sure
that she wants some
to be on her level like that's like yo
I'm attracted to men who kind of owned
their [ __ ] yeah but if you kind of
already came with with the thought which
is probably something that you didn't
think about where you're just like
you're giving off these like beta [ __ ]
vibes you know by saying stuff well
maybe you haven't said two words
honestly like the way he's communicated
the way he's meaning her I can't believe
I have somebody like you yeah like he's
like oh my god I'm so I feel so special
this and that and then a lot of the
times I think yeah I think when you
overdo it and you're too obsessed it
does have those vibes of like hey I'm
being objectified hey you're treating me
as like a sex object yours and a lot of
I mean I mean if he's not doing that is
probably coming off that way and it has
to be reciprocated like so guys like
we're so [ __ ] horny sometimes we do
objectify but it has to be they have to
do it back mmm and then it's balanced if
you're the only one firing off these
like what do you call it like like
you're you're showering her with all
these positive compliments sexually Oh
beautiful this and that right and you're
objectifying her you're like all baby
you look so [ __ ] hot i jack off to
your pictures or whatever I mean that's
my extreme if that doesn't happen back
to you well if that doesn't have bet it
doesn't go back to you yeah then it's
creepy mmm is very one-sided if she's
masturbating to your pictures and you're
masturbating to her [ __ ] pictures and
she's asking you to send her video of
you busted nuts yeah that is equal love
my friend yes but if you're the only one
doctor homie yeah if you're the only one
asking her for nudes and all this stuff
and whatever and it's just one-sided
perversion that's when it's [ __ ]
creepy yeah you need her to be [ __ ]
um objectifying you too man yeah wonder
hmm let's continue this cuz I feel like
we're catching on to something here hmm
so her arguments that she posted was
something I didn't agree with because it
honestly did not align with who I was as
a person she said that I was a fan
because I didn't see her for who she was
that I was caught up in the appearance
of dating her
you know look at that not dating her for
herself she made me sound like the
interactions that we had weren't
intimate slash close at all playing
video games with their brothers online
doing ASMR for her since that's how she
likes to sleep Nick [ __ ] dude
I'm sorry you sound like a [ __ ] he
doesn't get it man yeah he doesn't get
it she said I got caught up with the
potential of Fame from dating her I gave
her Ben if I gave her the benefit of the
doubt saying maybe I was but that
shouldn't discredit the fact that I
enjoyed the small interactions we have
from talking about it makes it bollocks
what I'm catching too is the girls
obviously a little insecure
well the authenticity of the
relationship he might really [ __ ]
like her well obviously he does you know
but then the way that she's taking it
could be like oh he's using me for my
clout yeah it seems I mean just to be on
his side a little bit
it seems like she's probably gone
through this type of experience before
yeah and you're having these signs of
stuff that's kind of setting off her red
flags
yeah you got to remember too that people
come with baggage Leia people come with
their own trauma with their own [ __ ]
maybe you set off a trigger maybe she
did date a dude that was using her for
[ __ ] Fame or cloud or whatever and
then she maybe she's in disbelief that
you actually authentically liked her
this podcast is brought to you by v or
my friends have you not heard of fiber
before well you are missing out and let
me wipe that single teardrop from your
face because you have been crying too
much and I know why because you don't
know where to find talent you don't know
how much it will cost and you can't even
be certain that certain freelancers on
certain projects will deliver well guess
what let's talk about finding freelance
talent for your business or project huh
finding the right freelancer can be
time-consuming frustrating and expensive
well Fiverr has your back because thanks
to Fiverr finding the right freelancer
doesn't have to be a struggle I have
used Firebird for every album art cover
that I have used the artists that I have
commissioned my goodness gracious can I
talk about outlines and how much they
deliver on time every time it's all
written out there for you let me check
this out for you okay
search by service deadline price reviews
and more you'll know exactly what you're
paying for upfront no negotiating needed
24/7 customer service because that right
there's a fiber guarantee and I love
fiber without fiber
I said fiber actually without fiber and
fiber I would be nothing I would be
constipated and waiting for my artwork
to always come take five and check out
fiverr.com you will receive 10% off your
first order by using my code in GB it's
so easy don't waste any more time and
get serviced you deserve by going to fi
ve RR comm code G B fiber it starts here
and if she's beautiful if she's got a
following you know a lot of those girls
are sometimes insecure of the
authenticity of someone's desire for
them and also to men like what were you
saying to her in terms of like were you
doing it too much or the compliments too
much there's a certain point too like
you guys have to realize like I think
sometimes we read these books and we
hear these advice stuff it's like make
sure that you praise these women like
their queen yeah there's that I guess
like I don't I don't really when it's
appropriate
yeah exactly when it's appropriate if
you're doing that all the time uh-huh I
mean why wouldn't somebody think like
you know this is very surfaced like all
you do is you know you're amazing you're
beautiful if I ask you to do something
you asked if I asked you to job you ask
how high and I think when it comes to
relationships to like if you have a
little bit of self respect for yourself
to write and you value yourself as a
person as well and you're all you're
doing is showering this person with
compliments and saying that you love
them which may be the certain
relationships like that do work but it
doesn't seem like that's what she wanted
she just wanted to maybe enjoy time with
you and just enjoy the experience so
every time you guys had a conversation
and in your conversation is well I can't
believe how beautiful you are you do
kind of sound like a fan yeah and you
don't connect with that individual
exactly so in your mind you're like well
I'm doing the nice guy thing what else
am I supposed to do you could have just
been yourself yeah
instead of like thinking that these
compliments and praising them shoes
showing love is showing a connection
yeah you know look we know
well Gina talked about this when we were
on big mood where she connects with a
lot of dudes like she has like boyish
tendencies that crazy little [ __ ] you
know so for her she connects with dudes
a lot like a game or whatever but a lot
of the times guys like when we connected
like I we talked about [ __ ]
yeah but she's like I wasn't trying to
suck your dick yeah like we were just
connecting and talking about [ __ ] yeah
um let's continue this to see if we're
on to something okay Laura was idea
standing here when it came to if I was
sexualizing her it was it seems very
disconnected or I'm guessing he's saying
her argument he's very disconnected her
arguments that saying beautiful or
gorgeous was sexualizing her to put we
were nailing it nailing the [ __ ] right
now yeah we get it how man it's hard if
argue for you bro
yeah or gorgeous was sexualizing her or
pushing her to stream or model is also a
way of sexualizing her I thought about
what I said to her that made me come off
that way and I thought girls appreciate
it and when the person they are
interesting gave them those compliments
but we just [ __ ] said the [ __ ] we're
now I get like that was coming from it's
like bro you want to encourage her and
you want to empower her but it's all
about how you're doing it there's time
and place for everything and I it's
weird because you're saying that we're
connecting we're connecting doesn't
sound like it they'll do it no it's this
is what happens to young boys right it's
like you get so in the fields yeah and
you're so excited that you're not
watching the [ __ ] that's coming out of
your mouth and you think just because
you're excited and you're sharing your
excitement with them that they feel the
same that is not a connection that is
you jerking off yeah that is you feeling
so good you gotta express yourself
mm-hmm but you got to pay attention do
they feel the same are they connecting
to you at this moment yeah if I was him
and and and I was clueless clueless I
this is what I would have done Oh baby
you look so good when you [ __ ] show
your cleavage when you stream and I'm
and that's why you get so many views and
this is extreme but I'm saying to that
effect that's what they hear yeah when
you go you need a stream more cuz oh man
like you so you so [ __ ] hot girl
that's not the [ __ ] point right yeah
and then for its kind of odd that you're
yeah there are other stuff with you guys
Bend up and you talked to each other
about certain things those are probably
the moments that you're that you're
cherry-picking that she probably also
appreciated as well but you're it's a
it's a it's a positive and negative and
then the negatives outweigh the positive
is what's happened exactly and it seems
like you're even like with the rhetoric
like the language that you're using
right now is you I thought that this is
what guys were supposed to do you're not
reading the situation you're not really
reading her as a person right so for
example if she's somebody that if she
feels like you've really felt like you
knew her right and she had issues of her
being sexualized by people like other
men do you think it's a smart idea that
every time that you talk to her you
mentioned how beautiful she looks
something about her physical size right
do you think that that's very smart yeah
there are women and you'll read tweets
and all this other [ __ ] like I like it
when my man says this this isn't it that
that to me but you still got to read the
individual it seems like she has issues
of people who want to be around her for
either cloud or the fact that she's a
very beautiful woman so you kind of just
digging into those insecurities by every
time you're with her or you're talking
to her online or over the phone and you
say and the the topic of your
conversation is how amazing she looks
what the [ __ ] are you supposed to think
dude yeah and there's no substance yeah
how is how is this the connection part
is where I'm a little bit lost man it's
like if you're talking about substance
that's not substance that's you reading
this textbook about how to keep a girl
around and make them happy and then you
kind of did this plug-in plaything well
it's actually selfish because he's like
I'm complimenting her I'm doing this and
I'm expressing how I feel but at the end
of the day we want and then I'm only I'm
only talking to my younger self - yeah
don't feel attacked bro we made this
[ __ ] mistake and we're just kind of
letting you know so you can limit how
long you stay in this mental state I
want you to get better obviously that's
why we're being hard on you so when you
hear this don't feel like you're a total
failure see it as an opportunity where
someone slapping the [ __ ] out of you
into reality because here's your
opportunity now to change there's a lot
of things that you're missing and you're
not seeing that's probably why you're
asking us like what's going on and we
were able to see the warning signs
because we personally went through this
[ __ ] and we did the same thing so the
goal
here is understanding what a person is
saying male or female doesn't matter and
their intent and in your ability to
connect with them you have a lot of
noise going on in your own mind because
your own voice inside is way louder than
what the person is saying hmm you think
hey man I'm doing the right thing I did
what I was supposed to do textbook one
I'm common yeah I'm complimenting her
I'm making her feel special I'm doing
this I'm doing that why is she going
crazy and all of a sudden [ __ ] acting
up this gets you to fall into the trap
of thinking women are the real rational
women are this winema like don't go into
that low level of thinking what it
really boils down to is how come you
weren't connecting what weren't you
listening to
she's obviously telling you and
communicating and telling you the points
we were able to see it before you even
explained it the goal here is to really
understand what people are saying not
everyone is gonna be great at explaining
but it's all about understanding what
people really mean when they're
communicating to you
yeah and she's saying yo you had a
chance bro and you blew it I was kind of
communicating with you and I was waiting
for that chance of connection of
whatever but you were so focused on just
living in your own feelings that you
weren't connecting with my feelings and
just doing things that you thought were
positive that you believed without
really seeing how it was affecting the
person that you were saying these things
to right so it's kind of like this right
imagine if um you know David doesn't
[ __ ] like chocolate but for his
birthday I give him chocolate and I'm
like bro is a gift is a gift why aren't
you [ __ ] grateful like why are you
being selfish like yeah
I'm buying you a gift in the first place
like isn't that good enough but it's
like bro I told you millions of times I
don't like [ __ ] choc I heard [ __ ]
fat people like chocolate
I saw a BuzzFeed article twelve reasons
why fat people love chocolate like I
don't get it bro like what the [ __ ]
yeah all right okay and I thought the
girls appreciated when the person who's
interested in them gave them those
compliments I recommended streaming as I
am a gamer as she is as well but never
truly wanted to explore the streaming
community she thought it was a place or
thinks that it's a place where girls go
to just sexualize themselves when I
stated that it doesn't have to be that
way as many girls in the streaming
community focus on their own content and
for her he suggested streaming as a new
platform for her to join okay my bad I
thought that he was telling her to go
stream more no no I see so she doesn't
know what streaming was that's why she
felt sexualized about that yeah for her
it would be four seconds she's more of a
musician for her music so showing her
creative processes doing live music
covers and for her fans something to
broaden her horizons modeling of course
is another avenue in the entertainment
industry that she should pursue and has
done some already which I which I was
fine with at the time I did give her the
benefit of the doubt that maybe I was I
don't know what that means maybe it was
oh maybe it was my fault but after
looking at I don't think that it was at
all but I want your insights was I
sexualizing her was I in the wrong on
this it doesn't align with my own values
but seeking counsel would be great from
you to when it came to cleanness it was
a hard pill to swallow one of the nights
when we were up all night on the phone
we talked about communication and
honesty and what it reflects she brought
up about trust what happens if she
doesn't text me and what's one of my
thoughts about it I told that if you
don't text me on one assume you're busy
and you don't want to be bothered with
and I'm also going to assume that you
are still doing the activity you told me
prior if something changes I would
appreciate a text saying if you're
heading out to do something such as Club
and hanging out with girls et Cie or
otherwise or otherwise I'm going to
trust you to be responsible she also
asked me if I have any thoughts if she
was with another guy I told her that I
trust you to be honest with me and
communicate with me if you're seeing
somebody else or a relationship that was
open no one has tied down do what you
want just let me know if you are and
that's all I asked when she brought up
this argument she says she doesn't want
to text if she moves from one local to
another from the music studio to a photo
shoot to a club size party and equated
that to being clingy I've been cleaning
before and I have had clingy girls who I
have talked to and for me I didn't think
this was being clinging at all of course
I also gave her benefit of the doubt
and maybe I was in retrospect in
retrospect I mean it could also be that
she's immature yeah
yeah she doesn't and some people just
don't have the same level of English
comprehension yeah there are people that
miss read text um especially in
long-distance relationships man like
you're not face to face or not I don't
know well he did say late night calls
right or whatever also - yeah it could
be taken so many different ways
yeah and this this this is hard to kind
of interpret just because cleaning this
once again is very subjective some some
let me just give you a quick story
that's cool like you're the dude that
says like you know what just communicate
me where you did be I don't give a [ __ ]
what it is it sounds very reason that's
very reasonable here's here's here's
this is why it's very subjective so I'm
also like that - or I was right the last
girl that I was with the for burial she
got really [ __ ] pissed at me because
she was gonna go on a weekend trip to
with her home girls to Vegas right and I
just said hey have fun no you don't even
need to text me or whatever just text me
when you're on your way back right just
have a good time don't even worry about
yeah right
what she later on I found out that she
was actually pissed at that response
well I was like why she goes like well
like you know the other friends that I
have like their guys usually check up on
and see if they're okay when they come
back home back at them like okay like I
didn't know that [ __ ] yeah you know so
I've had the I've had the opposite
reaction where I'm just like you don't
even got to call me yeah just [ __ ]
text me at your home or whatever or when
you're on your way back and I know that
you're good and so for her it wasn't
that I was cleaning it was like I wasn't
cleaning enough yeah you know so you
know it's hyper subjective - this just
sounds like she just doesn't like you
well at the end of the day we don't know
the whole story yeah so we're just
playing with these hypotheticals right
yeah because it is true that it could be
that she doesn't seem to like yeah she
just wanted some reasons to get the work
out but but at the same time I don't
like what she's doing which is passing
judgment and creating labels on this
dude yeah really yeah you are
sexualizing me you are you know dis me
like you're you're you're making me
you're a fan like like
those are pretty extreme labels to put
on a person those are multiple yeah and
I would say that is enough for me to run
away from this person
yeah like kind of what I guess doing
such a combative argument if like and
also a persecuting way to treat someone
and I the reason why I don't like the
way that you ended this stuff too is
like it's like one of the things that I
could do to change it's like well first
of all I don't even know if we're
speculating things but immediately
already you're wrong you're already at
fault yeah it's like when we were
talking [ __ ] like you was wrong yeah for
sure
you know because once again we're just
talking to ourselves but you know for
you it's like you know what can I do
next time it's like [ __ ] how
important is this girl to you like you'd
barely knew her well maybe he fell in
love and he never made a label and and
whatever but we all get heartbroken in
different ways I would like to say
though that that's just her perception
of you yeah doesn't mean who you are
exactly that's her perception your
confidence is too low first off right
you keynote speaker come on man because
you put her on a pedestal and you
believe the [ __ ] that she tells you of
who you are I mean you're you're sitting
here saying this isn't really who I
think I'm I am but I'm giving her the
benefit of the doubt
whatever she might be a complete buffoon
and have you totally [ __ ] up like she
barely knows who you are right
and so her calling you a fan her calling
you clingy her calling you all these
different things you know you don't have
to believe it completely you can watch
out for it and have an eye out like Oh
to make sure you check that ego in and
you you stay humble and all this which
is a great quality to have but you
shouldn't officially go what are the
things I need to change like now do you
need a change I don't know maybe you
guys just didn't mesh very well because
it seems like you're what I thought for
what you were doing didn't seem very
clingy at all like like if somebody
let's just say this dude if she really
really just was I guess infatuated with
you like you were infatuated with her
I think she would feel a certain way I
didn't check up on her that's what
happened in that other relationship when
I found out about myself and that
relationship
was like you know what she was kind of
right like I don't think I loved her as
much as she loved me yeah I told this
girl I was like you can [ __ ] anybody you
want I don't give a [ __ ] cuz that's my
way of showing love I'm like I love you
so [ __ ] much you can [ __ ] the [ __ ]
out of any dude and I'll still love you
and they'll come back to you and she's
like why the [ __ ] do you want an open
relationship like why won't you write
for me like why won't you be jealous why
won't you I was like okay technically I
don't want you with any other man but if
it comes to it and you want to [ __ ] a
million dudes you go and do that girl
and she's like no she's like why would
you say that like I use like I want you
to tell me I don't want to ever see you
with another man yeah you know okay I
get it but that's the basic gaiden yeah
yeah yeah I don't wanna be that guy I
wanna I want to be the guy that's like I
want your [ __ ] destroyed by everybody
and I'll still [ __ ] the [ __ ] out of that
[ __ ] to look like lunch meat when I'm
back [ __ ] and that's how much I love
you she's like the [ __ ] waiter dude
I'm like isn't that next level they're
like no no that's not amazing just
please be basic I mean I think you went
to extreme you did you took what this
guy said times 30 yeah I'll be like okay
like if you don't smell like another
guys come I'm gonna be [ __ ] pissed so
this guy says okay so of course I had to
move on and she had as well we're doing
our own thing now great pursuing our own
dreams in our respective industries I
guess you could say we support each
other from a distance but it's not the
same anymore I sought counseling during
this time as well to just process all my
emotions and I'm better for it I learned
a lot awesome dude really appreciate
that the last points that's question I
want to bring up is and the reason why I
wanted your opinions and answers for
those questions above from two people
have no bias towards or against me I
tell myself that maybe I did do
something wrong other peers of mine who
knew what happened said I'm just too
much of a nice guy and nothing is wrong
with me I don't know if nice guy is the
term I also asked myself but those were
her true arguments were those arguments
something to just use to end things
could be I've also be she found someone
else and she's bullshitting
yeah that's me there's so many things
you can't control man yeah so I don't
get it so I don't get intellectual and
mostly stimuli from a lot of girls now I
don't get a deeper connection with them
as tough as I think I am constantly just
comparing the girls I dated with her
that's already
of course she has privacy and it's up to
her to share that information but should
I seek out those answers from her bro
Europe you're obsessed
yeah he's he's absolutely sprung and
obsessed yeah and with this state and
with this mind I already knew he blew it
I already know he completely [ __ ]
blew it because you are too obsessed and
women or just humans don't talk like
that watch the [ __ ] right okay so he
goes thanks a lot for your answers and
opinions be real to me since I want to
learn from this mistake I don't want to
miss out on finding someone again but
this one out of the girls I've dated
seem different and if I messed up my
chance of happiness look at the rhetoric
you see okay we got a lot of work to do
brother okay but okay this is a lot of
oh my god a lot of humans do this yes
first off you can't ever ever find love
outside if you don't love yourself right
buhdeuce so here you this is what you're
doing you're trying to find love and
happiness in another person before
you're satisfied and confident and happy
with who you are so you're you're
seeking out validation acceptance she
doesn't want to be a part of that that's
why she's running from you she doesn't
want to be that person with that
responsibility she wants to be with an
equal yes loves themselves who's in
their element and that's not someone
who's just pursuing a career that's not
someone who's just doing their dream job
or a skill right that's someone who's
comfortable in their own skin
someone who's relaxed someone who's okay
if things don't work out or whatever but
he's there to love this girl
and accept her the way she is the way
that he accepts himself now this is a
difficult concept to understand because
naturally I think when we don't have a
strong sense of self what ends up
happening is we're constantly looking
for validation acceptance from our
friends acceptance from a girl to
chooses and if she rejects us then our
self value and self-worth goes down but
it has self confidence no matter how
much you get rejected you don't place
your own self being in this other person
just by your wording I can tell that
you put all your [ __ ] self-worth in
this girl's approval I want to say this
too because a thousand percent agree
with what joe saying right now because
you really really do remind me of myself
when I was 18
did you have a situation when you're
like might love this girl so much I've
never got to find anyone just like her I
talked about this before where I did
this whole story called my first love
and the basically the the second part
that I didn't complete but it was going
to lead up to that point it was like I
got the girl that I always wanted right
and I put her on this pedestal I
couldn't see all the flaws that were
happening in our relationships because I
chose to only cherry-pick the positive
things and ignore everything that was
bad and on top of that I did place my
value as a person based on what she told
me I was yeah if she said David you're
such a good person then I'm a good
person how are you yeah great if David
you're making me feel sad then like oh
I'm a piece of [ __ ] yeah or and it just
bred a lot of negative feelings because
things started going to me being a
jealous type of boyfriend because I felt
that she was drifting away from me but I
was the one that was pushing her away
there were so many negative things that
I did because I base my value as a human
being on what somebody else told me that
I was there was a point in my life that
I realized this where I think Jean and I
were talking to Gio I think I mentioned
with Gio with my very first girlfriend
where she looked at me she called me
annoying and it was a moment where this
is after we broke up and we were kind of
off and on and I was like what she said
hurt my feelings
because she was right I was like oh my
when did you realize you were annoying I
was just I would act up around her I
would try to make her laugh too much
it's just being the super obnoxious guy
because I was thinking for her approval
and attention yes and I was just [ __ ]
thirst for that [ __ ] yeah and then I
remember because we went to Community
College together I get something really
dumb and she just looked me you're
[ __ ] annoying and I was like [ __ ]
[ __ ] you mean I'm annoying and I went
home I just brood over that [ __ ] it's
like annoying what the [ __ ] where did
she go off call me and knowing I'm not
annoying like like I thought we were
cool you know they were off and on I
thought there's something there oh I
thought there's something there that
means you still want to be in a
relationship with meaning for her
[ __ ] attention could catch a [ __ ]
loser
yeah that was the first moment I rose
one of my biggest life lessons where I
was like dude you don't actually
have a [ __ ] backbone yeah your value
as a human being is based on how this if
this girl has feelings for you or not
yeah how big of a [ __ ] loser are you
that moment on I started being becoming
the catalyst for my own change almost
like from now on you don't feed for her
attention she is just her that's just
her you start making these changes and
it empowered me and it flipped the
script a lot it like at a certain point
she was with somebody else and when they
broke up I remember she came over and
she was like uh so it's like so I broke
up with him and I'm like so exactly I
was like cool was so what so she's
looking for validation from you now
exactly the other way around I know I've
got this [ __ ] he'll give me attention
exactly and I was like oh [ __ ] I have up
and I remember I was like I got a
backbone now dude and I was like this is
[ __ ] crazy I flipped it on you're
having the same problems that I did
right now and it's normal don't feel
weird it's not like you're a loser or
whatever everyone has this face well you
are loser but you are yeah that's true
everyone has a loser face yeah you're in
the phase that I was when I was 18 but
it's awesome because you can either move
on and learn or some guys they
continuously get fall into this trap
you're not alone in this dude yeah
everyone everyone goes through this yeah
so here's the thing man when you focus
on yourself everyone says this right
this is you got to build your confidence
you got to focus on yourself you got to
just be yourself what that means is
basically you have to put your
self-worth your love all that stuff
first you caring about yourself first
what that means is you have to forgive
the stupid mistakes you make all this
stuff but also believe and have this
confidence I think confidence at the end
of the day is believing in your thoughts
and actions before anyone else tells you
anything it's kind of stubborn but it's
also being very grounded to your real
self like you can look at yourself in
the mirror and see yourself as the world
sees you that's really what it's all
about and it's really [ __ ] difficult
to do but you can get there but here's
the here's the whole positive thing out
of all of this I can guarantee you that
standing here I can I can tell you that
if you do this what ends up happening is
you start attracting people of higher
caliber I know you pointed out something
earlier that
really struck out to me it was like I'm
never gonna find anyone just like this
it's hard for me to connect with people
she's so special there's no other girl
there's no other girl girls aren't that
you know whatever she was my last chance
of happiness all said that [ __ ] yo
there's a podcast where you should
listen to this [ __ ] talk about
getting dumped that his feelings yeah
I'm dodging this neighborhood because
that's yeah it's too close to her block
bro like I know that feel ya feel like
there's no one else better no one it's a
biology thing to like we're meant to
feel that way because you know we don't
we shouldn't want to lose the
opportunity of our mates you know I I
actually truly felt that way until I am
is something that I believed after I met
my first girlfriend because a lot of
dudes told me this stuff then I just
kind of believe they're like the first
love that you ever have nothing will
ever top that first love type of feeling
yeah and then you're just gonna kind of
like go around chasing that feeling but
there's other types of love out there
and it's that obsessive toxic kind of
yeah one-way love though I I was exactly
it's not real I was [ __ ] wrong too
because when I met Muriel the reason why
I went after her so hard is because that
that spark in that feeling that I felt
from my very first girl from when I was
an 18 year old I felt that way about
Muriel yeah I was like oh [ __ ] like I
taught I convinced myself that I would
never feel this way about somebody else
and I met a woman who proved me wrong
cuz you were you weren't open to it but
then you you finally saw and you
recognized it exactly because people
convinced me otherwise that it wasn't
going to happen because it didn't happen
for them because they were losers they
yeah they weren't open to it anymore
they got burned and then they said
thirst could be no other woman like this
I guarantee you right now there's damage
let's say they were damaged right so
they shut the door because they got so
damaged NAG I was in the same boat too
until I started to explore again and I
met so many intelligent women so many
fun awesome women right with great
personalities that I would have never
ever had the chances to me if I didn't
open myself
up again yeah but if I did one one time
believe that no it's difficult to
connect with girls period it's difficult
because you know for me I'm just I'm so
special but think about 300 million
[ __ ] people in the US alone now if
you go to other english-speaking
countries that also increases your
chances of finding someone like minded
even if you're a genius even if you are
a very very unique personality the
chances just out of that probability is
very high you will find someone that
fits you you got to look at it that way
it is no oh she was the one for me and I
let her slip away you know who the one
is the one is someone who reciprocate
that love back yes it's equal it's equal
man and and I guarantee you when you get
to feel that love which you will if you
put yourself out there again and you
explore and you you you you you you're
courageous enough to get burned again
and try when you finally find it it will
be so [ __ ] worth it because you think
right now this is your standard all the
moments were great because of this but
you were living a [ __ ] false dream
because it was only in your head it
wasn't reciprocated she was having her
own experience yeah nothing drops a
shared experience when you can share a
love when you're when you're in your
element and you you you you have a
strong sense of self and you meet an
equal so it doesn't happen if she's not
an equal she has to be someone who's
also just as confident if she's
depressed if she is also seeking out for
validation she doesn't love herself it's
gonna turn a little bit twisted if
you're in your element and she's
depending on you
you're gonna lose respect for her but if
it's two very strong independent human
beings coming together that is when [ __ ]
really really gets really interesting
yeah
and you know I know the the original
rhetoric of this it sounded very
accusatory on your side but basically
what we're saying is that you the the
experience wasn't equal
you know and that's what I'm really
gathering for me I feel like confidently
I could say that that definitely your
guys's experience wasn't equal he was on
cloud nine and hers just went downhill
yeah yeah and so even in like you guys
his relationship to it didn't seem like
he was on for a long time and seemed
like a few months yeah and you basically
put all your [ __ ] chips into one bag
and you thought that that was it you
know just perspective wise like I we've
here so many people who have been
relationships who have been married to
people they bought a [ __ ] ring they
had a whole ceremony they [ __ ] in
front of God their whole church
everybody else they got together but two
years later they get divorced they split
they have kids together they even split
and somehow they find love and somebody
else yeah right it happens for people it
happened in this very short instance you
just met somebody that wasn't for you
that's all that it is yeah you're
putting too much attention into this one
individual like you literally said am I
gonna find a chance for happiness are
you [ __ ] kidding the guy this is
infatuation its infatuation but that
last line says everything you're looking
for love and happiness and another human
being which will never be satisfying
because you're always gonna be looking
at this other person to make you happy
instead of you making you happy mm-hmm
and that is the most toxic thing you can
do to a human being is put that
responsibility on them are we gonna be
happy are you gonna make me happy can I
finally find my chance to be happy in
love it's like it doesn't work that way
and you kind of just prove you kind of
in basically what you wrote and I don't
even think you recognize this you
actually refuted and just proved
yourself wrong within the the paragraph
or the long diatribe that you wrote out
it was you're saying like I don't think
it's right for her to say that I was you
know quote-unquote obsessed or you know
just a beautifully but you show that you
are obsessed in your own writing you did
yeah which is insane which is hard for
you to recognize when you're in it in
your heartbroken
I trust me I [ __ ] understand I feel
for you so [ __ ] much you have no idea
yeah you know so I guess like what we're
saying is that because we've been in
those in your shoes before find yourself
worth when you find yourself worth and
you build yourself up to be an equal
especially in a relationship that's when
you get that reciprocal love and it
feels great right you can never tell
this day I always tell people you can
never walk
to a relationship putting someone on a
pedestal and not feeling worthy of them
mmm
he already started it that way I saw her
at the keynote speech I was way out of
her League
yeah from the first [ __ ] moment you
cannot look at another human being and
feel worthless you got to look at them
and say that's the one for me
that's the person that I'm gonna share
this connection with yep and for sure
just like looks-wise - with Mary Ellen
when I first met Muriel definitely from
an outside perspective it's like yo you
disgusting [ __ ] you're definitely not in
her League
I never thought that though right I was
like cuz you can't approach it that way
I've never thought she was out of my
league I was just more like this one is
mine yeah yeah and you gotta approach
life in relationship like this and it's
like if you don't respect yourself man
she's not gonna respect you either yeah
well guy I hope that really helped out
um yeah man that was actually a really
good question very in-depth I enjoyed it
very much hope that helps you out
remember every Thursday you'll see me
and Joe here dropping them [ __ ] I
want to say advice it's just more like
suggestions and gems of our personal
truth let us imagine up what's going on
with your scenario exactly so give you
all kinds of different angles and
thoughts of what can be going down but
generally the more in-depth it is like
that we can read between the lines and
figure out what's happening with you yes
I know like you wrote that [ __ ] a couple
months ago but I don't know if you're
still going through but I hope that
helped you out and give you perspective
but we'll see y'all next Thursday and if
you guys see us on Spotify iTunes
whatever all of those audio platforms
give us those five stars write in the
comments below and then we will see you
every Thursday because I'm trying to
help you [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] see y'all
next time peace